we have become lonelier we become more
isolated and this is not just an
American phenomenon by the way this is a
broader feature of modernity that the UK
Australia Japan and many other countries
are experiencing as well and it doesn't
mean that we should go back to 1920 or
1930 or 1950. but what it does mean is
that we have to recognize that if we
don't consciously make rebuilding
connection a priority in our individual
lives and in society more broadly if we
don't do that through individual actions
in the building of social infrastructure
in our communities then we will continue
to see an erosion of our relationships
and we'll see not only the health
consequences of loneliness which are
profound mental and physical but also
the economic and the National Security
implications of loneliness which make us
more prone to division and
depolarization